es como un salto atrás en el tiempo Uno
tras otro los países vuelven a imponer
normas estrictas en sus fronteras Tan
pronto como china permite viajar a sus
ciudadanos los países del extranjero
establecen medidas para limitar
severamente sus movimientos y es que la
preocupación por la falta de
transparencia Respecto a los casos de
covid-19 en China ha inclinado a Estados
Unidos por exigir a Los viajeros un test
negativo a partir del 5 de enero Japón
India Malasia e Italia fueron los
primeros en imponer medidas mientras la
Unión Europea tiene previsto reunirse
este jueves para debatir un enfoque
coordinado ante el aumento de casos
imágenes como estas con hospitales y
crematorios abarrotados preocupan al
resto del mundo todo mientras Beijing
levanta su estricta política de cero
tolerancia Después de tres años de
restricción de viajes ya que china
insiste que la situación está bajo
control señalando algunos medios de
comunicación occidentales a por
deliberadamente la situación
bastantes países han hablado
positivamente de nuestras medidas y
esperan que la situación siga
evolucionando en esta dirección
Pero según los informes casi la mitad de
los pasajeros de los vuelos de China
Italia dieron positivo en Kobe 19